- Une ville considérée comme
l'une des plus romantiques de la
planète, victime de son succès,
"la sérénissime" est maintenant
submergée par les touristes.
♪ ♪ ♪
En 12 mois, Venise accueille
plus de 30 millions de
visiteurs, c'est un nombre
qui ne cesse d'augmenter,
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a plus
de 500 touristes pour chaque
résidant. C'est comme si à
Montréal, on accueillait plus
de 1 milliard de personnes en
une seule année. Venise est
bien sûr unique, mais elle n'est
pas la seule à être envahie.
La vague touristique frappe
tous les continents.
C'est une industrie qui vaut
10 % de la richesse générée
sur la planète.
♪ ♪ ♪
Plusieurs facteurs expliquent
ce boom. D'abord, il n'a jamais
été aussi abordable de voyager
loin en avion. De plus en plus
de visiteurs viennent de pays
émergents. Et puis, il y a
Internet ; l'accès aux cartes
et aux recommandations facilite
les voyages à l'étranger
et toutes ces photos que
nous affichons donnent
des idées à nos amis.
En 2019, le tourisme de masse
n'apporte pas que des dollars :
il apporte également son lot
de complications.
Par exemple, il y a tellement
de gens, que se déplacer,
trouver son cliché ou encore un
endroit pour se reposer
devient une sorte de parcours
du combattant.
Et bien sûr, le tourisme de
masse pollue. Il y a tous ces
déchets que Venise peine à
ramasser et c'est sans compter
les gaz à effet de serre
produits pour venir jusqu'ici.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et à Venise, les touristes
chassent les résidents.
De nombreux appartements
ont été transformés pour loger
des touristes qui paient plus
cher. Les boulangers ont fait
place aux vendeurs de gelatos.
Pour protéger les trésors
de Venise, les autorités
ont fait quelques pas.
D'abord, ces gros navires
ne pourront plus circuler
aussi près du centre historique.
Et puis, pour voir Venise,
les visiteurs devront payer.
♪ ♪ ♪
Venise a également décidé de
sévir contre des comportements
jugés inappropriés comme
se baigner dans le canal
ou encore s'asseoir
dans un escalier.
Mais tout ça, ce n'est pas
qu'à Venise. Beaucoup de villes
doivent maintenant résoudre
le casse-tête du tourisme de
masse. Autour des lieux
les plus populaires, les
infrastructures sont débordées.
Chaque jour, il faut du temps
et de l'énergie pour effacer
les traces du passage des
touristes. Même les pelouses
n'en peuvent plus.
Certains musées ont maintenant
des difficultés pour bien
accueillir des foules records.
Ici, 30 000 personnes viennent
chaque jour dans l'espoir
d'apercevoir un portrait
au sourire énigmatique.
Et parfois, ces foules débordent
dans des petites rues paisibles.
Les touristes deviennent alors
des envahisseurs qu'on ne veut
plus accueillir dans
son quartier. Autant de signes
qu'il y a trop de visiteurs
au même endroit et qu'il faut
faire quelque chose.
À certains endroits,
les responsables ont décidé
de limiter le nombre
de visiteurs. D'autres imposent
des limites à la location
d'appartements de courte durée.
Ailleurs, on imagine
des circuits touristiques
alternatifs, afin de mieux
répartir la masse de visiteurs.
Évidemment, il n'est pas
question d'interdire
le tourisme, qui est d'ailleurs
en pleine expansion. Et c'est
peut-être là l'ironie,
il y a peu d'endroits
sur la planète où les dollars
des visiteurs ne seront pas
les bienvenus.